[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und christian sievers
[Musik]
hallo und guten abend alles hängt mit
allem zusammen unser planet ist im
grunde ganz klein und verletzlich das
war schon den weltraum pionieren
schlagartig klar als sie ihn das erste
mal aus dem all sein es wird auch heute
wieder ganz deutlich was gerade passiert
könnte über all das hinaus gehen was die
menschheit seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
erlebt hat warnt das
welternährungsprogramm der uno es sind
schlagzeilen über furchtbare folgen des
ukraine krieges in gegenden die tausende
kilometer entfernt sind krieg in einer
kornkammer gerade für die ärmere welt
was das ganz konkret bedeutet zeigt
unsere nahost-korrespondent ingo linea
teil jetzt am beispiel libanon diesem
traumhaft schönen land mit den
überwältigenden problemen im libanon
waren sie immer stolz auf ihre küche zu
recht jetzt müssen sie um brot betteln
wie lange noch können sie hier brood war
in der traditionsbäckerei von alice mahi
im süden beiruts kann das mehl jeden
moment ausgehen kann der alteingesessene
becker jeden moment schließen
wahrscheinlich reiche der weizen im
libanon nur noch drei wochen sagen sie
hier das land importierte bis zu 80
prozent seines walzen
der krieg dort hat voll durchgeschlagen
auf die mehlpreise das mehl wird jetzt
auf dem schwarzmarkt verkauft ein sack
mehl kostet 100.000 gira jetzt das exo
der siebenfache und wir müssen es
schwarz kaufen die brotfladen hier
müssten eigentlich mehr kosten ich mache
verluste
vor ein paar tagen bildeten sich
schlangen vor den bäckereien es gab
plötzlich kein mehl mehr für viele ist
brot unerschwinglich geworden
die explodierten getreidesilos im hafen
von beirut wie ein grabstein stehen sie
für den kollaps des landes für
hyperinflation und währungsverfall ein
land mit korrupten eliten das verbrennt
und nun den ukraine krieg als
brandbeschleuniger er liebt
die invasion der ukraine hat hier die
hohen preise noch höher getrieben und
verfünffacht und
wir haben meines erachtens jetzt ein
großes problem wir werden bald nicht
mehr genug weizen im land haben
derweil versinkt die hauptstadt an
vielen stellen im müll der staat kann
die müll unternehmen nicht mehr
auszahlen
tripoli die ärmste stadt lieben uns
schon vor der finanzkrise
niemand hier glaubt an eine zukunft
als nie war einmal unteroffizier 29
jahre diente er dem land seine rente war
1000 us-dollar wert jetzt beträgt sie
umgerechnet 50 dollar kinder und enkel
sind zu den eltern zurückgezogen zu
zehnt leben sie hier schlafen auf dem
balkon er ist krank seine medizin ist
unerträglich teuer geworden sie ernähren
sich von kohl und kartoffeln
er schämt sich zu erklären dass er keine
artikel vermisst
es gibt vieles über das ich nicht mal
reden kann intime sachen die meine frau
und meine tochter betreffen stellen sie
sich vor selbst unsere kleidung ist
überhaupt nicht mehr akzeptabel
ich trug noch nie ein t shirt mit einem
zerrissenen kragen meine tochter trug
noch nie eine eingerissene jeans
selbst in den kriegen der letzten
jahrzehnte waren sie nie hungrig im
libanon sagt er jetzt aber bricht alles
zusammen
jetzt muss der armee offizier und beruht
metal
351 prozent preisanstieg im vergangenen
jahr familien der mittelschicht rutschen
ab praktisch über nacht weil ihr geld
entwertet ist und die preise für essen
gleichzeitig rasant steigen und dass es
nicht nur im libanon so der
deutschlandchef des
welternährungsprogramms der uno ist
gerade zurück aus dem libanon martin
frick guten namen
genannt wie würden sie denn die
situation aus armut und hunger
beschreiben die der krieg gegen die
ukraine in anderen teilen der welt
gerade verursacht
also die situation ist explosiv wir
hatten bereits im januar bevor der
ukraine krieg überhaupt begonnen hat 150
millionen mehr menschen in hungers
gefahr als zwei jahre zuvor
kuwait klimawandel all das hat dazu
beigetragen
jetzt ist der überfall auf die ukraine
dazu gekommen hat die preise durch die
decke getriebener stripes staaten und
familien an den rand
wie konnte es soweit kommen wie in
deutschland sind abhängig von russischer
energie offensichtlich andere staaten
sind abhängig von ukrainischen und
russischen weizen haben wir auch daran
eine mitschuld dass das so gekommen ist
wir haben über die letzten zwanzig
dreißig jahre eine konzentration auf dem
markt gesehen auf sehr sehr wenige
grundnahrungsmittel weizen gehört dazu
es gibt nur sieben große produzenten für
weizen drei länder halten im prinzip 60
prozent der weizenvorräte der welt
insofern ist die verwundbarkeit der sehr
hoch wer ist denn jetzt möglich um auch
mal einen ausweg aufzuzeigen dass man
aus diesen weiteren lieferungen wieder
raus kommt eventuell oben steigt auf
lokales saatgut und dann in dieser
schweren krise vielleicht auch eine
chance liegt wie sehen sie das
mittelfristig und langfristig sicher wir
müssen vor allem in afrika wieder viel
stärker diversifizieren kurzfristig
brauchen wir aber marktzugang wir müssen
auch der ukraine ermöglichen weizen
exportieren zu können denn so schnell
können sie das globale system nicht
umstellen jetzt ist es ja aktuell so
dass viele internationale geldgeber ihre
finanzströme gerade umleiten auch die
ukraine braucht er hilfe braucht geld es
gibt bereits dieses jahr schwierige wort
von der sogenannten
entwicklungspolitischen triage wie
erleben sie das
wir müssen das bereits seit monaten
betreiben im dezember haben wir in jenen
nationen um die hälfte kürzen müssen um
überhaupt noch alle menschen erreichen
zu können die dringend auf unsere hilfe
angewiesen sind das ist leider für uns
das tägliche geschäft wir haben momentan
eine situation in der wir nur die hälfte
derjenigen die wirklich akut hilfe
brauchen auch tatsächlich versorgen
können welche weiteren folgen haben dann
aus ihrer sicht jetzt diese furchtbaren
hunger szenarien für die welt ist auch
mit unruhen etwa zu rechnen am ende ja
also wir haben das gesehen beim
arabischen frühling als der rasant
gestiegene preis bestimmt nicht der
grund aber der auslöser für den
arabischen frühling war jetzt haben wir
eine situation die schlimmer ist wir
haben zum beispiel einen viel stärkeren
dollar und wir haben die folgen der
pandemie an denen viele länder sehr zu
kämpfen habe die allermeisten
afrikanischen zum länder zum beispiel
sind rettungslos überschuldet und können
sich diese preise gar nicht leisten sagt
der deutschlandchef des
welternährungsprogramms der uno martin
frick afrika zwischen dank für das
gespräch
dann ging
reden wir mit der politisch
verantwortlichen die deutsche
entwicklungsministerin svenja schulze
war gerade im libanon ist jetzt in
äthiopien gelandet und von dort bei uns
in der sendung frau schulze guten abend
der guten abend euromillionen an
förderung aus deutschland für die uno im
libanon um den hunger zu bekämpfen haben
sie versprochen können sie das
versprechen halten wo doch ihr haushalt
ausgerechnet ihr haushalt gerade gekürzt
wurde
naja mein haushalt wird ja jetzt wieder
aufgefüllt dadurch dass wir einen
ergänzungs haushalt machen aber es ist
ganz wichtig zu sehen dass putin jetzt
auch mit dem hunger sozusagen krieg
führt und deswegen müssen wir dem etwas
entgegensetzen die lebensmittelpreise
steigen gerade enorm und wenn die hilfe
weiter gehen soll dann braucht das
welternährungsprogramm einfach mehr geld
und es braucht auch zusätzlich noch eine
bessere koordinierung und für beides war
ich jetzt eben die letzten tage
unterwegs man hat so ein bisschen den
eindruck der deutsche finanzminister hat
gerade für alles mögliche geld aber eben
nicht für die entwicklungshilfe wie viel
mehr geld oder anders gefragt wird wie
viel mehr geld rechnen sie denn ganz
konkret sagen sie doch bitte einfach mal
eine zahl auch für den wichtigen
mittwoch im bundeskabinett wenn es um
dieses geld geht
wichtig wäre dass mein etat eben
möglichst so bleibt wie er ist weil wenn
wir die hilfen fortführen können dann
können wir auch weiter in der welt
helfen aber noch mal es geht nicht nur
um geld es geht auch darum dass wir die
hilfeleistungen auf der welt besser
koordinieren bei so einem land wieder
levanon der ist nicht in der lage
verschiedene geldgeber zu koordinieren
das müssen wir anders organisieren und
deswegen habe ich ein globales bündnis
für die ernährungssicherheit
vorgeschlagen damit dem vorschlag war
ich bei der weltbank jetzt gehe ich zur
afrikanischen union und setze darauf
dass wir in einer weltweiten
koordinierung einfach mehr aus dem geld
noch machen können dass das ist dieses
bündnis ist ja zunächst mal ein
schlagwort aber sie haben es gerade
angesprochen fehlendes geld ist eben
nicht alles auch die strukturen sind ein
problem im libanon zum beispiel sind sie
eine katastrophe korruption
vetternwirtschaft das ist ja auch mit
millionen aus deutschland dann eben
nicht zu retten möglicherweise sogar im
gegenteil
was muss sich denn generell ändern damit
krieg in einer region nicht hungersnot
für viele weitere bedeutet
wir müssen generell besser voraus klaren
in solchen regionen wie dem libanon da
müssen wir mit der regierung von der
regierung verlangen dass sie mehr macht
und gleichzeitig vor ort den menschen
helfen wir machen das mit dem
welternährungsprogramm ganz konkret ohne
die regierung ganz konkret vor ort damit
das geld eben auch wirklich ankommt
beides ist notwendig den druck auf die
regierung aufrecht erhalten und
gleichzeitig hilfe vor ort leisten
vorstellen wir müssen noch über eine
zahl reden die einen verstört muss man
sagen zurücklässt wie kann denn das sein
dass china aktuell die hälfte des
verfügbaren getreides dieser welt hortet
in silos und sich damit die welt auch in
diesem punkt quasi abhängig macht
159 millionen tonnen bunkert china
600.000 tonnen fehlen dem libanon
es fehlt im moment nicht an mit
lebensmittel lebensmittel sind da es ist
auch weizen da auf der welt was nicht
mehr möglich ist es dass die länder das
kaufen weil sie als auch das geld nicht
mehr dafür haben deswegen china ja die
haben enorm viele lebensmittel für sich
gewundert weil sie natürlich auch für
die chinesische bevölkerung sich darum
kümmern dass genug lebensmittel da sind
und deswegen ist es wichtig dass es
keine
exportbeschränkungen gibt das weiterhin
mit diesem weizen auch gehandelt wird
dass er in die welt exportiert wird weil
ansonsten die lebensmittelpreise noch
weiter steigen und das ist etwas was wir
unbedingt vermeiden wollen und deswegen
gehen wir auch in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit so vor dass
wir nicht nur jetzt akut helfen sondern
auch programme machen dass die länder
sich selber helfen können also hier in
äthiopien wird zum beispiel einfach mehr
selber angepflanzt sie sind von viel
mehr in der lage sich selbst zu
versorgen und das da ist nicht viel
hilfe auch gelungen und das müssen wir
einfach in noch mehr ländern schaffen
sagt die deutsche entwicklungsministerin
svenja schulze aus addis abeba
zugeschaltet vielen dank frau schulze
danke auch
und die beiden gespräche haben wir aus
termingründen ganz kurz vor dieser
sendung aufgezeichnet die deutsche
debatte um waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine steuert mit voller kraft aufs
parlament zu die einen sagen richtig so
denn dort gehört sie hin die anderen
bemängeln dass ein brisantes thema jetzt
zum parteipolitischen zankapfel werde
oder gar zum parteipolitischen spielchen
in krisenzeiten fakt ist cdu und csu
also die größte oppositionsfraktion wird
einen antrag einbringen der fordert
sofort schwere waffen einschließlich
kampfpanzer an die ukraine zu liefern
die union nennt das halb augenzwinkernd
angebot denn das problem für den
bundeskanzler ist auch abgeordnete
seiner regierungsfraktionen würden den
antrag inhaltlich wohl sofort
unterschreiben das angebot wahrnehmen
fertig wäre die regierungskrise wie die
ampel so ein szenario verhindern will
berichtet david gepaart er gilt als
präzise modern und feuer stark der
schützenpanzer marder als stolz der
bundeswehr in einem eigenen erklärvideos
bewaffnetes der mit einer 20 mm baut
maschinen kann ohne einen
maschinengewehr mp3 und der panzer
abwürfe für milan die ukraine hätte ihn
gerne aus bundeswehr beständen oder
direkt von der rüstungsindustrie
rheinmetall hat beantragt 100 stück zu
liefern doch die kanzlerpartei spd
zögert sind sie dafür als spd oder
schließen sie das aus diese frage steht
derzeit nicht zur debatte weil die
panzer die die deutsche industrie
herstellen nicht direkt eingesetzt
werden können sowohl was die was das
personal auf dem panzer anbelangt weil
die soldatin soldaten in der ukraine
nicht diese machen systeme nicht kennen
das heißt nicht dass sie dazu nicht in
der lage wären aber es benötigt lange
schulungen und langes training die sind
inzwischen sehr gut ausgebildet das
heißt sie sind auch in der lage sehr
rasch auf neue systeme zu lernen und es
ist eine deutsche überheblichkeit hier
davon zu reden dass die ukraine das
nicht könne das ist eigentlich im grunde
genommen eine eine lüge die hier
verbreitet wird auch eine anmaßung der
streit um waffenlieferungen spitzt sich
zu die union will die ampel vor sich
hertreiben legt für donnerstag im
bundestag einen antrag vor der fordert
unverzüglich über angebote aus der
sicherheits und verteidigungsindustrie
zu entscheiden material und waffen aus
firmen hand darunter schwere waffen wie
gepanzerte waffensysteme darunter kampf
panzer und schützenpanzer sowie
artillerie systeme in kürzester zeit an
die ukraine zu liefern die ampel
wiederum wirft der union
parteipolitische spielchen vor die dem
ansehen deutschlands schaden sie feilt
an einem eigenen antrag zu
waffenlieferungen den auch cdu und csu
unterstützen sei es gibt von unserer
seite auch einen ausgestreckten arm ich
finde dass es keine frage wo man in
regierung opposition verfallen mussten
es muss mit unseren partnern dafür
gesorgt werden dass die waffen der
ukraine ankommen die gebraucht werden
auch schwere waffen das hat gehen wir
jetzt den weg den ringtausch ringtausch
bedeutet dass etwa osteuropäische
staaten schwere waffen liefern meist aus
sowjetzeiten deutschland für ersatz
sorgt aber eben nicht selbst liefert
doch genau das fordern einzelne ampel
politiker seit wochen immer wieder
koalitions scharmützel ein beispiel eine
staatssekretärin spd etwa wirft der
vorsitzenden des
verteidigungsausschusses
fdp indirekt vor als rüstungslobbyist
den unterwegs zu sein die wiederum nennt
das äußerst beschämend die tweets wurden
mittlerweile gelöscht und zeigen doch
dass mitunter vergiftete klima einer
koalition die sich verhakt hat
beteuerungen zum trotz wir haben keinen
krach in der ampel bei dem thema wir
haben manchmal ein bisschen eine
auseinandersetzung darüber tempo aber
die richtung der ampel politik für eine
wirklich umfassende unterstützung der
ukraine
da sind wir uns alle drei ampel partner
völlig einig ihnen reicht diese
unterstützung so noch nicht schande für
scholz ruft eine kleine gruppe auf einer
pro ukraine demo vor dem kanzleramt und
fordert schwere waffen so fort es dürfte
eine hitzige sitzungswoche werden im
bundestag eine regierung unter druck zu
liefern
40 deutsche diplomaten müssen russland
verlassen das russische außenministerium
hat sie ausgewiesen wegen der zitat
unfreundlichen politik berlins anfang
april hatte deutschland 40 russische
botschaftsmitarbeiter ausgewiesen
amerikas chefdiplomat war in kiew und
anthony blinken kündigte dort weitere
militärhilfe an so viel wie möglich so
schnell wie möglich die aktuelle
situation vor ort im osten der ukraine
lassen uns jetzt schildern von unserem
reporter dort dara hassanzadeh ist in
die nähte guten abend aus
sicherheitsgründen ein bisschen dunkler
wie ist denn die aktuelle lage kann man
das als ruhe vor einem sturm beschreiben
die frontlinien in der ost ukraine sind
weitgehend unverändert es gibt kleine
örtliche verschiebungen doch die
ukrainischen streitkräfte halten den
russischen angriffen stand doch das
bedeutet auch dabei sterben menschen
oder werden schwer verwundet allein ins
militärkrankenhaus von chapeau richie
was nur 90 kilometer entfernt ist werden
jeden tag im schnitt 40 bis 50
verwundete soldaten eingewiesen zudem
hat russland die
luftangriffe auf die ukrainische
infrastruktur verstärkt es wurden heute
in den letzten 24 stunden fünf
güterbahnhöfe oder verteilerstationen
getroffen auch dabei gaben kamen
menschen ums leben da was braucht denn
die ukraine derzeit am meisten und wofür
es besteht schon die möglichkeit und ich
würde sagen die sehr groß dass die
ukraine genau das braucht was sie
fordert schwere waffen schützenpanzer
kampfpanzer denn es kann der ukraine ja
langfristig nicht nur darum gehen dass
sie die fronten frontlinien hält sondern
sie muss im grunde auch die stadt kehl
sollen wieder einnehmen die jetzt von
den russischen kräften besetzt ist
person ist der schlüssel für die lange
brücken in die grimm aber auch wäre es
ein einfallstor richtung westen nach
odessa und im schlimmsten fall wäre die
ukraine dann langfristig von dem meer
zugang abgeschlossen
abgetrennt und das bedeutet für die
gesamten agrarexporte dass die häfen
nicht mehr zu nutzen wären und das
könnte die existenz auch der rest
ukraine bedrohen beim thema agrarexporte
sind wir wieder beim thema und am anfang
unserer sendung da war herzlichen dank
für dieses update aus dem osten der
ukraine heute abend und heinz bleibt
hier noch beim thema im ersten
nachrichtenüberblick ja im kanzleramt da
gab es heute eine große konferenz zur
aufnahme und integration der menschen
die aus der ukraine nach deutschland
geflüchtet sind vertreter von bund
ländern kommunen und zahlreichen
organisationen waren zudem so genannten
round table ukraine geladen neben der
unterbringung und versorgung rückt auch
die integration der menschen stärker in
den blick mit themen wie kinderbetreuung
schulbildung zugang zum arbeitsmarkt
die spd-vorsitzende ascon hat gerhard
schröder nach dessen umstrittenem new
york times interview zum parteiaustritt
aufgefordert es gehen sagte im
deutschlandfunk schröder agiere seit
jahren nur noch als geschäftsmann man
solle aufhören ihn als elder statesman
als altkanzler wahrzunehmen die
parteispitze hatte schröder aufgefordert
seine mandate bei russischen
energiekonzernen aufzugeben
rund vier wochen nach der landtagswahl
hat das saarländische landesparlament
anke rehlinger zur neuen
ministerpräsidentin gewählt erstmals
seit 23 jahren führt damit die spd
wieder die saarländische regierung an
die bisherige wirtschaftsministerin
erhielt bei der geheimen abstimmung 32
von 5 51 stimmen drei leer ist die
spd-fraktion sitze hat morgen sollen die
ministerinnen und minister vereidigt
werden die spd hatte bei der wahl ende
märz die absolute mehrheit erzielt
bundespräsident steinmeier hat die grüne
bundestagsabgeordnete lisa paus zur
bundesfamilienministerin ernannt die
auswirkungen der korona pandemie sowie
des russischen angriffskrieges in der
ukraine stellten laut steinmeier
zentrale herausforderungen für ihre
arbeit daraus folgt auf eine spiegel die
vor zwei wochen ihren rücktritt erklärt
hatte
die weltweiten militärausgaben sind im
vergangenen jahr also schon vor dem
russischen angriff auf die ukraine
erneut gestiegen weltweit floss die
summe von mehr als zwei billionen dollar
in rüstung so das
friedensforschungsinstitut sipri am
meisten haben die usa china indien
großbritannien und russland ausgegeben
deutschland wird hinter frankreich auf
platz sieben aufgelistet
die türkei bietet sich der welt gerade
als vermittlerin zwischen russland und
der ukraine sieht in vielen punkten mit
dem westen wieder an einem strang und
dann heute das osman kavala ein
unternehmer und kulturförderer ein
aktivist für menschenrechte muss
lebenslang in haft ein türkisches
gericht sieht ihn als umstürzler der
türkische staatspräsident sieht ihn
schon lange so kavala sitzt seit bereits
seit mehr als vier jahren ohne urteil im
gefängnis der europäische gerichtshof
für menschenrechte sagt zu unrecht aus
der türkei jetzt jörg brase
nach dem urteil herrschten bei covers
anhängern fassungslosigkeit trauer und
wut lebenslange haft ein urteil nicht
nur gegen hossmann kavala nein es war
ein schlag ins gesicht jeder opposition
gegen den präsidenten
vertreter dieser opposition waren
prozessbeobachter und wussten dass auch
sie gemeint waren
es ist nicht möglich dass ein bürger
freigelassen oder freigesprochen wird
für den der präsident persönlich die
anklageschrift geschrieben und den er
selbst verurteilt hat dieses urteil
wurde im präsidentenpalast verfasst und
es wurde heute nur noch vorgelesen
kavala der erfolgreiche unternehmer und
kunstmäzen es scheint er wurde für den
präsidenten zum persönlichen feind ein
intellektueller kritischer feingeist
freund der europäer die vorwürfe gegen
ihn seien haltlos er müsse freigelassen
werden hatte der europäische
menschenrechtsgerichtshof
2009/10 geurteilt als einige europäische
botschafter forderten dieses urteil
umzusetzen drohte präsident erdogan mit
ihrem rauswurf niemand soll er sich in
türkische angelegenheiten einmischen
wetterte erdogan das heutige urteil
wirkt wie eine bekräftigung dieser
drogen es handelt sich um ein politisch
motiviertes urteil und zeigt glaube ich
auch noch mal ganz stark das was man
vergessen konnte angesichts der ukraine
krise der annäherung an die eu in
letzten jahren aber nichts ist in
ordnung in der türkei in politische
repression geht ungebremst weiter
mit kabbala wurden sieben weitere
angeklagte der sogenannten g sie
proteste aus dem jahr 2013 zu hohen
haftstrafen verurteilt damals waren
zehntausende gegen die politik der
regierung auf die straße gegangen mit
den heutigen urteilen wurde
zivilgesellschaftlicher protest zum
putsch versuch erklärt
wir wissen dass dies ein absolut
fingierter prozess ist von anfang bis
ende es gibt keine beweise für strafbare
handlungen es ist ein schauprozess und
es gibt den willen damit weiterzumachen
jetzt da wir in die phase der
präsidentschaftswahlen einzige
deutsche organisationen wie die mercator
stiftung arbeiten seit jahren mit kavala
zusammen sagen er sei ein brückenbauer
zwischen europa und der türkei diese
brücken würden nun eingerissen bei
politischen verfahren würde man erwarten
dass die inhalte inhaftierung in dem
moment endet wo die kosten größer sind
als der nutzen der inhaftierung an einem
pfeifen aus man kann da ist es sehr
schwer nachzuvollziehen wo der nutzen
liegt die kosten sind jedoch immens denn
der türkei könnte nach dem heutigen
urteil nun tatsächlich der rauswurf aus
dem europarat doch es scheint als sei
das dem präsidenten ziemlich egal
so und jetzt was
280 zeichen mit 44 milliarden dollar zu
tun haben eins klärt auf die
online-plattform twitter und tesla chef
elon musk haben sich nun doch auf ein
übernahmeangebot geeinigt demnach sollen
musk den kurznachrichtendienst für rund
44 milliarden dollar kaufen sind meine
ziele sind diese nachrichten einzuordnen
also das nach eigenen angaben beste und
letzte angebot von elon musk den
kurznachrichtendienst twitter
vollständig zu übernehmen hat nun
jeglichen widerstand seitens des
konzerns brechen lassen musk greift nach
immer mehr macht und hat einmal mehr
erfolg der us milliardär ist nicht nur
der reichste mann der welt hat mit dem
elektroautohersteller tesla pioniergeist
erwiesen fliegt zum mars und schnappt
sich nun mit twitter einen der
wichtigsten medienkonzerne der welt die
twitter aktie gerade eine new yorker
börse im plus mit 6 prozent ein blick
auf diesen kurs der twitter aktie wird
wohl bald geschichte sein denn musk will
twitter nun von der new yorker börse
nehmen damit muss er keine rechenschaft
mehr vor aktionären oder der
amerikanischen börsenaufsicht ablegen
46,5 milliarden us dollar stehen maske
für den kauf zur verfügung
er soll durch 25,5 milliarden dollar
kredite von us-banken und zusätzlich
tesla aktien im wert von 21 milliarden
dollar finanziert werden erst vor gut
einem monat ist elon musk finanziell
beim online-kurznachrichtendienst
eingestiegen und mit fast 84 millionen
followern einer der aktivsten nutzer und
nun bald twitters alleiniger besitzer
sein credo twitter hat ein
außergewöhnliches potenzial ich werde es
freisetzt was genau das heißt bleibt
abzuwarten das soziale netzwerk facebook
zeigt jedenfalls anschaulich was es
bedeuten kann wenn medien macht in der
hand eines einzelnen mannes liegt sie
noch meine vielen dank
in der chinesischen hauptstadt peking
wächst die angst vor einem grösseren
lockdown nachdem mehrere dutzend corona
infektionsfälle entdeckt wurden haben
die behörden in einem stadtteil mit rund
dreieinhalb millionen einwohnern für
diese woche massentests angeordnet mit
die behörden warnten dass sich das virus
schon seit einer woche unentdeckt in der
stadt verbreitet haben könnte
jährlich wird am welt malaria tag an die
erklärung von abuja vom 25 april 2000
erinnert afrikanische staats und
regierungschefs hatten darin einen plan
zur bekämpfung der krankheit beschlossen
laut weko stieg die zahl der
malariafälle 2020 verglichen mit dem
vorjahr um 14 millionen an mehrheitlich
in der afrikanischen region die whu
führt dies unter anderem auf die
schlechteren versorgungsmöglichkeiten
während der korona pandemie zurück
experten zufolge begünstigt auch der
klimawandel die verbreitung der
krankheit mehr dazu gleich im anschluss
im wetterbericht von katja hornuf all
unsere welt in einer schwierigen lage
das war sie ihren diesem montag und um
0.05 gibt's dann unsere heute schnell
update mit christopher wehrmann von uns
allen hier im heute journal an sie einen
angenehmen abend wieder sinn
[Musik]
guten abend heute hat sich westlich von
uns ein kleines tief entwickelt und das
zieht morgen hier über die mitte
deutschlands weiter nach osten es hat
schon kräftige schauer und gewitter
heute nachmittag mitgebracht und schauer
und gewitter begleiten uns auch in der
nacht ganz anders sieht es hier
nordosten aussah ist es häufig klar es
bildet sich auch mal nebel und dort
droht bodenfrost morgen gibt es in der
mitte und im süden kräftige schauer und
gewitter im norden ist es dagegen
deutlich freundlicher und die
temperaturen steigen auf 9 ist 17 grad
nach dem regen wird es in den nächsten
tagen deutlich sonniger und wieder
wärmer heute ab 25 april ist welt
malaria tag malaria ist eine
infektionskrankheit und kann für
kleinkinder lebensgefährlich sein früher
gab es sie auch bei uns jetzt vor allem
noch in afrika und den regenwaldgebieten
verbreitet wird malaria durch spezielle
anopheles mücken die mögen es feucht und
25 bis 30 grad warm also tropisch genau
in diese richtung entwickelt sich unser
klima die temperaturen steigen und im
sommer und herbst regnet es oft stark
bleiben pfützen länger stehen vermehren
sich mücken rasch so könnte sich auch
die malaria mücke im laufe des
jahrhunderts wieder bei uns ausbreiten
klimaschutz ist also auch
gesundheitsvorsorge guten abend